In the Democratic Republic of Congo,...
...a yellow fever epidemic has been declared in three provinces...
...after confirmation of 67 cases of the disease,...
...with another 1,000 suspected cases being monitored.
In the US, in Pennsylvania, a 51-year-old man faces charges...
...after police find 12 girls living in his home,...
...including an 18-year-old and the two children he fathered with her.
In Germany, Volkswagen's former boss Martin Winterkorn...
...is under investigation for allegedly manipulating the market...
...by holding back information about emissions cheating at the automobile giant.
In Italy, Virginia Raggi is elected the first female mayor of Rome.
And finally from India, the new government in Assam...
...pushes a campaign to change the time zone in the northeast...
...due to residents complaining of too much sunlight in the day...
...and not enough in the evening.